si usted o alguien que conoce padecen de
presión arterial alta este vídeo le
ayudará a comprender qué es y por qué es
importante mantenerla bajo control
con el tiempo la presión arterial alta
dañará las paredes de sus arterias este
daño puede ocasionar condiciones de
peligro de muerte
por ejemplo una arteria puede
debilitarse y formar un engrandecimiento
llamado aneurisma la pared puede
romperse
y sangrar en el tejido que la rodea
en otro ejemplo el daño a la pared de
una arteria puede ingresar determinadas
sustancias en la sangre como colesterol
grasa y calcio estas pueden acumularse
para formar lo que se denomina placa
a medida que la placa crece se reduce el
flujo sanguíneo en la arteria
las células sanguíneas pueden pegarse a
la placa y formar montículos sólidos
llamados coágulos los coágulos de sangre
reducen aún más o bloquean completamente
el flujo sanguíneo si esto sucede en el
cerebro puede provocar un hace v
si esto sucede en el corazón puede
provocar un ataque cardíaco en otro
ejemplo el daño en las arterias en los
riñones puede reducir su capacidad de
funcionar correctamente esto puede
provocar una enfermedad renal
como último ejemplo el daño a las
arterias hace que el corazón lata con
mayor fuerza lo que eleva la presión
arterial aún más y puede ocasionar una
insuficiencia cardíaca
si tiene preguntas acerca de la presión
arterial alta o cualquier medicamento
que le hayan recetado consulte con su
médico es importante tomar los
medicamentos siguiendo las instrucciones
e informar acerca de cualquier efecto
secundario que pueda tener